I think I know why this is called
project Almanac because it's about
something that happens and starts
unraveling the timeline if you change
one thing you change a few things and
it's just bad Almanac it's gotta be
project Almanac
so project Almanac is a time well before
I say it's a time travel movie let's
call it what it really is
it is a found-footage movies another one
of those found-footage movies for people
unrealistically film every facet in
every aspect of everything going on I
guess I could pieces together and make
it a movie it's like it's real but in
this particular fan footage movie this
really smart kid he wants to go to MIT
and his friends run across these DARPA
schematics for a time machine like I
think we can build this so they start
building it which is all fun and you're
watching time-travel stuff happen else
and us things happen and things changed
and oh my god time travel suspense
that's what happens in those turns out
though this movie's actually pretty
enjoyable first of all you have time
trouble that's fun no matter what we all
stop back to the future when we were
kids we were like that's cool all right
in a leaves right out the gate
I guess time-travel movies have a leg up
on other things I like seeing the
process that it takes to make this time
machine work you know like all right
trial a trial B trial oh my god it
worked
all the while to have to deal with high
school and which is enjoyable enough but
at a point the movie starts dragging his
feet it's like all right no one's jumped
through time yet this is not a very long
movie so come on pick it up let's do it
we didn't come here to see high school
we came to see time-travel let's start
doing it and it's really cool you're
like I love this I would be doing this
kind of you're having a good time
you're vicariously living through these
kids and then things start to go awry
that they didn't think about because you
can't change things in the past without
drastic changes in life and then this
starts putting on the brakes and slowing
out you should be fun cuz you look at
spring break but it really concentrates
on this whole Spring Break thing and
they're all just hanging out because
they have all the time in the world now
but it does it to build this romance
between this main dude in this main girl
and you're like I don't care about that
come on let's get back to the time sure
then it picks up and all the bad
starts happening and then you're more
entertained just have been uneven you're
like oh yeah that's interesting right
it's kind of boring oh wow it's
interesting again alright pick it up
come on it just kind of does that
throughout the movie some of the acting
serviceable some of it's good some of
it's not good at all couple of things
that irritate me I mean you're dealing
with time at this point so it's you know
theoretical alright fine whatever
you can't help it there are a moment to
this movie er
like I can't just shake that off it's
just not I didn't grow up on the movie I
guess I don't give it a pass but it that
just wouldn't it don't like I'll explain
it a little later and I'll put spoiler
alert for people who are like spoiler
I'll keep it spoiler light I don't feel
like it'll be a spoiler but just in case
so all in all project Almanac is a
pretty fun movie it's an inconsistent
movie you have fun and then you get
bored and throughout the movie I like
some of the character dialogue a couple
of supporting crew I was like you make
the movie couple of the other supporting
crew them like you are completely
useless all in all it's a found footage
romp through time and the found-footage
genre being completely overused at this
point it's actually a pretty
entertaining found footage movie I will
say project Almanac it's a pretty good
time no alcohol required here's the
thing where I was like I don't think
they did that right it's Ruby
establishes if you go back like a day or
two you will run into your past self if
you run across your past self like
example
alright I've now uploaded this video if
I'm watching this video tomorrow and I'm
like you know what I want to change
something there I couldn't just go back
in time and re film it because I would
run into me here who's filming it
already gotta be like
project Almanac
so project Almanac is a time well before
I say it's a time travel movie let's
call it what it really is
it is a found-footage movies see what I
mean it'd be kind of awkward like that
so our group of time travelers they go
back to Spring Break they're all hanging
out the main dude has a shot to make a
move on the main girl that he has a
crush on he doesn't take it so they get
back to their normal time he's thinking
about it he's like I should have taken
that shot so he goes back alone and then
puts the moves on or he's hanging out
with her and he takes a shot but that
doesn't make any sense because his whole
group was there because they went back
the first time so they were all there
including alternate him where was the
him who was hanging out with the girl
who didn't make the move you can't just
take him out of it he was there there
should be another him there with a group
that's already there that went back
before for some odd reason that's the
thing that made me go it's inconsistent
movie you can't do that I don't know I
didn't kill the movie for me or anything
like that I'm not gonna hold it against
the movie saying that should exist that
reminds me of Back to the Future to old
Biff goes back in time gives the Almanac
to his young self goes back to the
Future drops the DeLorean off all is
right right oh because after he gave the
Almanac to his past self if you went to
the Future it would be the alternate
future that he just created from giving
the Almanac to his past self but he
ended up going to the future that he had
just left which was the unaltered one
telling you man so what time-travel is
hard I so project Almanac have you seen
it what did you think about what are we
that comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more